hello strange loop
welcome to dom step browser dance party
how many of you know
what meat spaces is show hands
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna say hi to meat
spaces
everybody wave hi meat spaces
all right um if you don't know what it
is it's a
like gift based chat site which is
super cool um so
who am i my name is jamison dance
i'm 27 years old i've heard jokes about
my last name for 27 years
and today i realized that the title of
my talk has the word dance in it
and now all those jokes have become
reality um
i'm jurgison on twitter and github i do
javascript jabber a podcast about
c sharp just kidding it's about
javascript
you guys probably guessed that who am i
24601 right
i always think of that when i hear the
phrase who am i i'm not john valjean
um but i am a former international
rock superstar and i will show you proof
this is my high school band the goodsman
brothers um
there are probably more people in the
band than were watching us right then
um but it's not the the number of people
that watch you it's
the purity of your rock or something
like that i don't know
to prove this is our
high school band
we're pretty terrible the reason i play
that is to establish credibility so a
key when speaking
is to show the audience that you know
what you're talking about i'm talking
about music
clearly um i was a young mozart
and so i therefore you should listen to
what i say about music
um so we're gonna be talking about the
web audio api
i'm not an audio engineer um i'm not a
fantastically talented musician i'm just
a software developer that decided to
tinker with it and i say that to give
you hope because
if you are an audio engineer or good at
music or smarter than i am which is
probably true
and you can do way more amazing things
than i'm doing um
so it's to show you the possibility so
today we're going to start an edm band
edm is what you say instead of dubstep
if you're really pretentious
but it's the same thing we're going to
start at dubstep band
with your help and
we're going to do that with the web
audio api so
by a show of hands how many people have
played with the web audio api
well there's a fair amount of people
cool um so for those of you that don't
know
it's an api in the browser it's in
chrome firefox safari
opera is um maybe working on i don't
know
and internet explorer whatever
you create this audio context that's
what this fancy diagram is showing
you create this audio context object on
the page and then you create
this graph of nodes that create and
manipulate sound waves and you hook them
together
and then you pipe the result of that to
the speakers and that's how you can
play with and generate music in the
browser it's similar to
an analog synth so this is the wood
audio api
um this is a moog synthesizer and it has
some of the same concepts as the web
audio api so
there's the whole the the audio context
here
is is the synth itself the whole thing
there
there are you can see all these chords
connecting stuff together
you could think of these as different
nodes in the in the api
some of them produce sounds some of them
manipulate sound
and then you pipe it all out to the
speakers so like the keyboard is would
be a node that produces sound
i don't know what any of these other
things do actually but
um i assume they do sound related things
okay uh how many people have laptops
i need you to open up your laptops you
all
probably have them open anyways but i'm
giving you permission to open up your
laptops
so um there are some closure people here
there's some people playing with
overtone
and overtone is incredible it's a tool
for generating music with closure you
can do live coding with it in a repel
and it's um the abstractions it provides
for creating music
are a lot better than the web audio api
so in a world where overtone exists
why do you care about the web audio api
if it's so low level
you care because you can do stuff like
this everybody open up a browser
tab does everyone know how to
um type multiple lines of code without
submitting them in the browser console
no
okay uh you have you hold down shift
enter to put in a new line without
making the browser evaluate it
so i need the people let's see
on the right side of the room to type in
these lines
i need the people in the middle so kind
of the middle of these two
rows to type in these lines and don't
hit enter
don't like start them yet then i need
the people on
the left i guess it'd be your right your
right to type in these lines
and i'll give you a minute
i know you all want to be on your
laptops anyways so this is just an
excuse to do that
um this is the strange loop orchestra
by the way so you are all now members of
the strange loop orchestra
can you see it is that big enough is it
hard to see
i still hear typing so i'll stall for a
little bit um
does anyone know any jokes
i do not i'm bad at stalling okay
are people done typing
no okay i'll wait a little longer
um by the way this slide presentation is
an html5
um but it wasn't built with grunt it was
built with gulp
so all those problems that he talked
about are
just kidding there's still problems
um oh and turn up your volume i hear
some volume noises so yeah
that's important all right
it's like little applause that's so cute
ready
okay i'm going to conduct you guys so
when i raise my hands like this that
means hit enter
to evaluate the code the middle i'll get
the code okay
ready
there were some typos in there i heard
i heard some stray notes
that just means it's art um you don't
understand my art if my music is bad
okay give yourselves another round of
applause that's the strange loop or this
drive
so what we did there was uh generated
some sound with the web audio api we'll
talk a little bit about
how we did that and explain how to do it
um and
give some code examples that are easier
to understand than what i typed in there
so this is an example we're just going
to create a simple tone
yep that's her tone and this is the code
that does it so we're creating a new
audio context here
you usually only have one of these on
the page at a time and then you do all
of your work
with the same context we're creating an
oscillator node which is a node that
generates a wave
and then we're setting its frequency to
300 that controls the pitch
of the tone that it plays and then here
we're connecting the node
to the destination of the context which
is the speakers
so when we when we showed that diagram
earlier there was a node connected to
another node that's what we're doing
here
and then we call start on the node which
starts it playing
um so for a little bit more explanation
we need to talk about how
sound works so what you perceive as
sound
comes to your ears as variations in in
pressure so it's a wave of pressure that
hits your eardrums that
triggers a nerve that sends a signal to
your brain
so this is kind of an example of the the
areas of
high pressure where there are a lot of
molecules in the air and then low
pressure
and that corresponds to this wave here
where the amplitude the
kind of height of the signal corresponds
to high pressure
um where there are low low amount of
molecules that's
the low part of the wave i guess um so
that's how that's how sound works
um there are these waves they hit your
ear you hear sound
and we can show what the sound wave that
we're generating looks like
like this so that's our sound wave being
drawn on a canvas
while it plays this slider controls
the frequency and you can see when i
change the frequency
the that's a little loud
the distance between these peaks in the
wave get
longer the lower the frequency goes that
makes the note
sound lower and then when i change the
frequency to be higher
pitch goes up right so that's how you
control pitch it's just
the distance between the the the peaks
or the frequency
of the sound wave um
we'll talk a little bit about digital
audio just to understand how computers
process it most of the time so um
that was a sine wave it's easy to
compute a sine wave
lots of sound is made up of a lot more
complex waves and it's hard to just
store a function that computes that wave
so computers cheat and they just
digitize it
so they just sample the height of the
wave at a bunch of different intervals
and then turn that into an array of
numbers so most of the time when
computers process audio they're working
with these
arrays of numbers this is called linear
pcm data it's kind of the lowest level
rost representation of digital audio um
that'll come up a little bit later all
right so
i've made a theremin does anyone not
know what a theremin is
it's okay i see a couple hands i'll
explain it it's an instrument
that you control it shows up a lot in
sci-fi movies
where it has these wands and it detects
like the electromagnetic signals from
your hands or something like that
and you just move your hands up and down
and make these weird wobbly noises
so like this classic 60s sci-fi movie
sound like laser gun
that's usually a theremin um
this is the web audio theremin so we
have
our theremin here and then here it's
going to graph
the um sound that we're making
so
hang on i practice playing a song and i
wanna see if you guys can recognize it
oh i need to practice a little more
so there are a couple things to notice
here one is that the shape of the wave
is different
than the last wave we looked at this is
called a sawtooth wave
so where the sine wave was very smooth
and flowing this
rises and then drops off and rises and
drops off like that
that affects that doesn't affect the
pitch of the sound like which note it's
playing it affects the tone
um so when we move
up and down like that that affects the
the frequency you can see they get
closer together
um i want to see if you guys can guess
what it does when i move from left to
right
does anyone have an idea i see your hand
um i don't know what those words mean
he said makes the envelope or cutoff
shorter
i'm going to explain it by filtering so
the web audio api has oscillator nodes
we already looked at those it also has
what's called a biquad filter which
allows you to change the shape of the
wave
by emphasizing certain frequencies or or
parts of the wave so you can see as we
move
from left to right right here it's it's
kind of smoother
um and then it gets a little more jagged
the further right we go
so if i could keep my mouse perfectly
flat um you wouldn't hear a change in
in the pitch you would just hear that
change in tone and that's reflected in
the change in the shape see how these
lines are kind of
jaggedy um that's a scientific term
jaggedy so we'll show the code to do
this so this is the same as before
new audio context make an oscillator
this time we set its
type to be a sawtooth wave by default
it's a sine wave
here's where we make our filter and then
instead of connecting the signal to the
destination we're connecting the signal
to the filter
um and then we connect the filter to the
destination so we're piping the wave
through the filter and then all the icky
dom code i left out because
you guys know how to do that but we're
basically hooking up
the frequency value to the x position of
the mouse and the
signal the the sawtooth wave value
sorry the filter value to the position
of the mouse on the x-axis
and then the signal value to the
position in the mouse on the y-axis
so that's how we do that another
important part for making music is
loading buffers
this did not work so i have to refresh
the page
um
sorry it also didn't ask for
all right um so you can load a
sound into a buffer which is how you
would kind of use music from from a
server so
use music files instead of just
generating the waves yourself which is
helpful
so this is an example of how to do that
this is the same song the goodsman
brothers
greatest hit as before
and then it's graphing the signal right
here in a
svg thing so we'll show how we did that
there's um
why are you laughing
okay oh i forgot about this
um that's why this is how i write code
normally so i don't know that says that
you're you're laughing
um so there's a little module i made to
load buffers basically you make an xhr
request
and then actually i'll show that code
i'm a rebel i'll show some live code
can you see this okay
so it takes in an audio context
um it returns a callback or sorry a
function that takes in a path and a
callback
and then it just grabs the file at the
path
make sure the response type is array
buffer that's important for the web
audio api to be able to decode it
and then you call this function on the
audio context called decode audio data
you just pass it your data it's an array
buffer which means it's just like the
array of
bytes and it um the web audio api has
things built in to understand the
different music file formats so
og mp3 web wave however you pronounce
that
it'll just take it and turn it into this
audio buffer which is the way you you
deal with
um these music files in the web audio
api
uh and then if we go back here
yep so we have our buffer here we make a
buffer source
which is a node that uses a buffer to
generate sound instead of
generates it with a function and a wave
and then we
set the buffer we set it to the we
connect it to the destination and then
we
start it which starts playing the buffer
you can make it loop you can seek to
different places within the buffer so
you have a lot of control over how you
you play the sound um
this is helpful for building stuff like
this
this is the ascii drum machine beats js
we can throw some
hi-hats in there
yeah you start to dance it's okay
you don't need to stain your uh
all right we'll stop it so this is
beats.js it's a little drum machine that
just takes a string
turns it into a scheduled track that
that loops
um i'll show how to use it so you load a
bunch of buffers
you um beats jazz just looks at what
these things are can you see this by the
way this seems too small
and that does not
the mess we're in
these are h's
anyways this is kind of the key which
instrument this
this line is going to play so this is
h sn for snare bd for bass drum
um over here
we map these strings to buffers so the
beats library just knows whenever it
sees this string play this buffer
and it schedules a little loop here
we're
giving it our track so this will just
play
kicks on the bass drum and loop through
that and then you call start playing
um all right so that's cool
dubstep has visualizations there's like
guys in giant inflatable suits and i
don't know weird stuff like that so we
need some kind of visualization
for uh our edm band our dubstep band
and we're gonna use something called
flocking
so does anyone know what flocking is
already
a few people flocking is
this very simple set of rules that
controls
the behavior of a group of particles and
makes them look like
they're kind of this intelligent swarm
so it was meant to mimic
flocks of birds or fish or bats i guess
they used it in a batman movie
which is cool because this is the
closest i get to being batman
um the way it works is it creates these
particles it gives them random velocity
vectors and then each tick through it
iterates through the particles
and looks at all of the neighbors of
each particle
and the three things it tries to to
manage are the cohesion which is how
close it wants to be
to its neighbors the uh
oh geez kind of look at my notes now you
guys are gonna know
the secrets that i hide
uh
there they are okay the cohesion
uh means that they try and stick
together the alignment means they try
and go in the same direction as their
neighbors and the separation means they
try and
um not clump too far or too close
together
because then they'll hit each other and
the pixelated birds will die
so these three simple rules just
make this complex simulation that looks
a lot like some kind of life it's kind
of like conway's game of life
right you have these simple rules they
work together to make something cool
um so this is just it running with no
input or changes or whatever
one thing we can do is change
some of the parameters of the flock in
response to the beat
so we're going to start playing a beat
from beats.js
and i think it's on like the third
note or something like that i don't know
every so often you see when they all
split apart
that's because we're changing the
cohesion um
to make it so they don't like being
close together and then we change it
back so they
come back up so this is how we're going
to make our our visualization
and then it will stop playing to the
beat um
so we're almost there uh yeah this is
just an example so beats.js this library
has a beat emitter callback
it'll get called every time it loops
through a track with the times that the
the beat will fire um
and then we just set a timeout to do
whatever we want on the beat on that
time
um we also need to we should also talk
about the uh
the timer in the web audio api so if you
guys
if you know about um how set timeout
works in the browser you know it's not
reliable you can schedule something with
a set timeout and it won't fire the
exact millisecond that you schedule the
timeout for
for audio you really need a reliable
clock otherwise you get
clicks and gaps and it sounds terrible
it's really easy to perceive it's not as
easy
to notice if you're kind of just moving
divs around on the page
but if you're generating audio your ears
are really good at detecting
discontinuing
discontinuities and sound so
the web audio api has its own clock um
it uses seconds instead of milliseconds
because who needs consistency on the web
um and when you make an audio context it
just starts ticking
you can always grab the current time and
then you can use
um you can use that time to schedule
different nodes to start playing or stop
playing or change their parameters at
certain times
and it's it's in a different thread in
the browser so it won't get messed up by
page rendering or or anything like that
okay um we're getting close um one thing
that's been missing
is wob so wob is
in dubstep when it goes
and that's a key ingredient of dubstep
you can't have dubstep without wob
so we have to talk about the secret of
wob so
we talked a little bit about how sound
waves work
this is building on that knowledge so
here's our carrier signal this is the
signal that's playing
the note that we're listening to we use
another
wave called the modulator and we
feed that into the carrier signal to
generate this modulated signal
so um you see how it kind of combines
the waves
what do you think this will sound like
down here so if this is playing a single
tone
just constant same volume everything
like that what do you think this one
will do
it will yeah it'll get louder and softer
this is the amplitude right so when the
amplitude gets
higher here that's louder when it gets
lower here it'll it'll get softer
and that that's that's wob that's how
you make the wob
which sounds like i'm mispronouncing
that's how you make the web but that's
not
what i'm saying so we'll show an example
of that
oh well got some distortion
that's the wob this is the code that
does it so this is the same as before we
make a context
make an oscillator then we make a gain
node gain
is what you say instead of volume if you
do music
for elitism i don't know no it has the
real reasons but it's it controls the
volume
and then we create a gain oscillator
so the oscillator is the thing
generating the node
or the note the gain node controls the
volume so we pipe the oscillator through
the gain node
and then we hook up our gain oscillator
to the gain of the gain node so it's
making a sine wave like this when the
wave goes up
the gain on the gain node gets higher
which makes the signal louder when the
wave goes down
the gain on the gain node gets lower
which makes the signal quieter
so we have two oscillators running at
the same time but only one of them is
generating a sound the other one is
controlling the amplitude of the first
one
does that kind of make sense
okay cool we're getting close
um you are also in our band
but the button is not there
so you have to see behind the curtain
again
see gulp is reliable
all right there we go um this uses react
as well for maximum
buzzword density so
uh oh i'm gonna swap out the the mic
really quick i have to tell the sound
guy
so i don't blow your ears out
okay um
what do the lyrics of dubstep songs
sound like
they're always nonsense right it's like
the clouds are so
high higher than the sky
which doesn't make sense um we're making
javascript dubstep so we need some
javascript related nonsense
what about undefined is not a function
that's some nonsense right okay
so to participate in the band um
we all have to record an audio track
together
that's what we're gonna do right now are
we all agreed undefined is not a
function is that gonna be the the vocal
track okay i have my iphone microphone
high fidelity pretty good at picking up
sound
i'm gonna hit this record button and
then we're all gonna yell undefined is
not a function
record it okay ready one two
three undefined is not a function
okay now i gotta i'm gonna plug back in
the sound
here
okay we're good uh we can check
the quality maybe
two three undefined
okay we got the countdown
oh geez so
no joke the hardest part of this
presentation was
i'm i'm bad at the dumb it was figuring
out where
in the in this div i am clicking so i
can draw this drag thing on it
that took me so long undefined does not
function okay there's our track good cut
good recording guys we should round of
applause good job
all right we'll save that for later um
which is right now
so oh
it's barely on there okay this is the uh
where we're gonna put everything we use
together so we know how to make drum
tracks we know how to generate sound we
know how to sync everything to the beat
we know how to um record sound and
manipulate it
um
is missing
the visualization all right it's gonna
get smaller that's okay you can still
see that
so here's um my beautiful ui
for the the drum machine slash i don't
know
music performance thing that i that i've
created
we'll start the uh the verse kicking off
that's too loud
okay kick off the bass track
all right and then they need some little
dd leaves on the end
yep there it is it's beautiful
oh no what happened to my drum track
there it is okay every dubstep song
needs like the breakdown right where it
gets quiet and then it gets louder and
that's where you take all your ecstasy
to get ready for the drop
and then it gets a little faster a
little faster
oh now
oh no okay there it is all right
obviously some coordination problems
in our song a couple days we'll fix it
in post-production a couple days in the
studio
make it okay we have made dubstep
there we go and then we have
our visualization all at the same time
we just need some people up on stage
with those
swirly glowing light sticks dancing and
then we will have completed
our browser dance party
okay that's the browser dance party give
yourselves a round of applause for the
participation
great work
so i i know i glossed over some aspects
of this at the end these slides are
all be up on github you can look at my
code and then
discard everything i said after you look
at my code um
are there any questions
i haven't no
i mean you'll get the current
time i guess
so you can use it to get the current
time you can also use it to schedule
changes to properties on nodes but i
don't think there's a way to just
call an arbitrary function in response
to the timer
so i don't know how you would hook into
that
i don't know sorry sounds like room for
improvement maybe you will be the one to
do that
any other questions yeah in the back
it's well it's it's the web so it's
always in beta i mean they're still
working on the standard
um let me show some
resources here make these bigger
so um the spec is being worked on it's
broken
things in a couple ways already
throughout its life
cycle i think they just made a few more
backwards incompatible changes
but it's i don't know it's in a usable
state
it's not perfect yet but you can
definitely build on it and the browsers
it's in are the evergreen browsers so
as long as you update your code when
they break the spec then it'll just work
in in people's browsers
did they answer your question okay
i'm sorry i haven't been repeating the
questions in the microphone um the
question was is the audio api in beta or
not
any more questions
it's i don't have the internet so it'll
just do nothing if i click on that
um i think it's called signal processing
with the web audio
no that's the talk it's a free online
book
if you just google o'reilly web audio
api it's got a pretty thorough
introduction
um they have some live code examples on
the page which is always cool
yeah um
it's on my github which is jurgeson
uh i guess we'll just put it in the
video comments or something like that
when it gets released
where was where will we find it on
github was the question yeah another
question
um
um that's a good question so the
question was what other destinations are
supported besides the speakers
you can always feed the output of
of your graph into what's called a
script processing node
which will just give you the raw digital
audio remember that
slide we showed with the digitization of
audio it'll just give you that buffer
you can use that to i don't know turn it
into a blob save it as a url do whatever
you want with that
the web audio api also supports um so it
supports real-time audio which is when
you're generating and playing back audio
in real time
you can do it faster than real time as
well so if you want to record if you're
generating a bunch of audio with sine
waves and you want to record i don't
know 30 seconds of it you can just play
it all back in a couple seconds because
it's not
tight it doesn't have to be tied to the
clock any other questions
what were you using for the void's
visualization
that was just an npm module called
boyd's
do you know if anyone's like this
they have yeah oh there's actually the
question was what am i what module am i
using for
for the visualization um
oh my markdown broke well there are
a few cool things that people have made
with this or with the web audio api
flocking js is this
online playground um
it kind of does all the grunt work for
you in the background
and then you just have to write a
function that that kind of
returns a synth so it's a good place to
play with it without having to deal with
all the
boilerplate setup you need there's a
collaborative web audio editor this is
by the death tone he'd spoke at jsconf
about it
it's basically it's it looks like a
professional audio interface
editor thing like ableton live or
something and it's uh hooked up
to the cloud so you can record tracks
together with other people at the same
time
and someone oh that's cloud to butt plus
that's why you guys are laughing
a cloud music editor
there's a browser plugin i have that
changes every instance of the cloud
to but
it's it's never quite bitten me in this
way before though
oh man anyways splice is a commercial
company that just released
uh this is a thing you can pay for and
they have real
actual musicians using it to create
tracks and to allow other people to
remix their tracks online any other
questions
cloud to butt plus look it up all right
show me what you make
if you make cool stuff tweet it to me i
would love to see love to learn from you
guys thank you very much